last year i sold a 12 million business
two businesses for just under 50 million
and two cars that were both exotic cars
and a four million dollar house in
austin and that left me with
really no
i would say i mean i did have like
equities and stocks and stuff but i
didn't really have like material
belongings and i did that because i
wanted to have a reset and so what i
want to do in this video is talk to you
about one um what life was like or why i
made the decision two what life was like
after i made the decision what i learned
and then some of the realizations i had
along the way and what i'm doing now and
so if you don't know who i am my name's
alex mozy i own acquisition.com we have
a portfolio of companies that's about 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you i make these videos because i
just want to transfer whatever lessons i
have learned along the way to hopefully
help some other people let's dive in so
why did i go and sell everything last
year i think the biggest thing is it
felt very heavy i felt like i had all
these material things that were weighing
me down and taking my attention and i
have lived my life in seasons and what i
mean by that is like i look back on my
life and i've had like three to five
year seasons i had a season where i went
to college and then became a management
consultant i had a season of running
gyms i had a season of licensing gyms
and starting three kind of bigger
companies which is what we just sold
last year and the season that we're in
now which is now we just full-time you
know find uh service-based businesses or
e-learning businesses that are doing
like one to ten million a year um in
profit and invest in them right that's
what we do now i thought that i wanted
to have and i said this often my dream
state going into this was i want to have
an unlimited credit card and just
consume my lifestyle with one bag and my
wife and i more or less did that after
we sold so i basically got rid of all my
clothing
with the exception of like one bags
worth and we set off and spent a bunch
of time in different areas and part of
this was because we wanted to figure out
where we wanted to live and i have a the
the requirements for what i was looking
for i have this big list that i made uh
before we did this journey and i'll tell
you where we went in a second but i
wanted something and this might be
useful for you to like you know think
through i wanted things to be walking
distance from me so having lived in a
handful of different areas very
expensive areas very cheap areas um i
realized that 90 of like my life is
really just predicated on the things
that are in my immediate walkable
distance and so i wanted nature to be in
walkable distance because we like layla
and i walk probably an hour or two every
day um i wanted restaurants because we
got to eat a lot and having the
convenience of just something that we
can go eat regularly is really you know
useful and has high utility for us
number three is i wanted to have a very
sick gym in like the immediate vicinity
and that's because for me i've realized
that that's a very important part of my
life in terms of like things that bring
me joy and then number four having a
grocery store really nearby that sounds
silly but like it's actually very
convenient to have growth so those are
like my big walking distance things that
either have to be inside the building or
within like walkable distance in terms
of like things that the home that i
wanted to have requirements was a view
of either the ocean lake or mountain
like that was important to me because at
least for me when i look out the window
like it's nice super fast wi-fi a hot
tub slash pool with a view an office and
studio three bedrooms minimum ideally
more um and a big balcony or patio all
right those are like kind of the house
things and then additional features were
kind of like more area specific so it
has to be reachable by amazon prime i
want it to be in a zero tax state
because for me
the difference between two different
areas is much more dependent on the sub
market that you are in so like for
example people like to say that they
love a certain city but i think if you
really think about it there's just a
handful of tiny little neighborhoods
because like you as one human probably
are like oh i visited nashville one
weekend nashville is awesome and what
you're making a judgment on like
nashville is the
three to ten people that you spent time
with
and the you know
six places that you went when nashville
has a thousand places and so it's like
we take these we make these snap
judgments on areas based on such limited
data they're almost irrelevant you could
have a terrible experience in nashville
because you had the wrong people or the
wrong three to five locations that you
visited and an amazing one in cincinnati
because you were in a very wealthy area
and that was the microcosm and you
probably wouldn't even know the
difference if you were in the suburbs of
cincinnati versus the suburbs of
whatever you know what i mean and so
i've realized this because layla and i
actually spent two years on the road
before we settled down to start the
three bigger businesses doing gym
turnarounds and so we actually were in
33 cities in 18 months and we spent like
two to three weeks in each one of them
and so we got a lot of feel for what
america feels like and what's
interesting is there was a couple times
where i was i was walking through like a
target and i remember thinking to myself
i knew the target like the back of my
hand because almost all of them were set
up the same way and i was like what city
am i in again and the thing is is like
most cities especially in like the
higher end areas if that's what you're
trying to get into they have the whole
foods they have a target they have the
same chains of rust like it's all
so similar that we have these like super
strong beliefs about like one city
versus another and they're almost
identical when you get into like the sub
markets right and so for me that's why
and i've made videos about why i don't
think you should make decisions based on
tax i have no marginal difference in
living and so since there is no marginal
difference i then say okay well if
there's no difference then i would
rather pay less in taxes and so that is
why zero percent tax was one of the the
requirements or preferences rather i
wanted to have a way to meet lots of
neighbors that were interesting and so
this is one of those like i prefer to
live in a wealthy area because then and
ideally ultra wealthy and i say that
because i've lived in quote wealthy
areas and you get a lot of upper middle
class and there's nothing wrong with
that it's just that those people don't
necessarily understand like my lifestyle
or the things that i find important they
just had very different priorities than
me and it it became very difficult to
have any kind of meaningful
conversations or relationships in
general because there's just not a lot
of common ground the next one is ideally
and i covered good entrepreneurs scene a
central airport close by and so i'm
showing these things so that maybe these
you can add them to your own personal
list as you're looking for houses and
and where you want to set up shop a
central airport close by because i do
travel a lot and or people travel to me
you know if you're in a you know b or c
market sometimes you have to have always
connections to get everywhere and for me
that's a massive pain and so i prefer to
have a big airport that i can get direct
anywhere i want to go or people can have
direct to me i wanted to also lock it
and leave it flexibility so because i
travel and because i like flexibility
and that is what i kind of optimized for
i wanted to be able to lock the house
and leave it and then come back and not
have like a ton of stuff that i had to
like figure out i wanted to also be in a
market that i could attract talent so if
i was going to hire people which is
probably certain i wanted to be in a
market that i could attract the best
talent and if i was going to have a more
an office i would want the office to be
within 15 minutes of my house and part
of that is predicated on the idea of if
if you're going to have something that
you have a business where you have
in-person employees then that would be a
function i currently don't have this
and i think that we made the decision um
over the last year to go remote and i'll
walk through that in a second but sold
everything these are the requirements
that i had and then layla and i spent
basically the last nine months living
all over the place and so we went to
just for an idea we spent a month in
cabo which was awesome by the way really
sick like really really like cabo
personally and maybe that's just the
microcosm that i experienced but the
microcosm that i experienced in san jose
and san lucas we spent two weeks in each
was really nice and i actually really
enjoyed it a lot it was totally
americanized you could like you could
get around not speaking spanish with
like zero problems and everything was
really cheap um which is also a nice
benefit and like the real estate there
like you can get an ocean front infinity
pool you know six thousand eight
thousand square foot mansion for like
five million dollars which you know in
the us would probably be like 20. so i
mean like there's still just a massive
price difference and if you did choose
to
live there six months or more of the
year you actually uh functionally pay no
state income tax as well as a fun side
benefit so we went to cabo we went to
scottsdale we went to flagstaff we went
to bear lake in utah which is like a
beautiful mountain lake set up highly
recommend really nice and then uh
we went to vegas and there was a couple
we went to southern california for a
while we we went all over you know what
i mean and you're like that's a lot of
pacific southwest and that's true so i
guess it's not that all over um but for
us those are kind of a lot of different
it had a lot of different feels to it
and so after going through that where we
basically owned nothing just had the
bags and traveled and just you know
leased the lifestyle for for for lack of
a better term and i would say to give
you an idea in terms of like the scale
of what we were renting we were probably
renting stuff in the neighborhood of
like 50 to 100 000 a month in terms of
cost so like they were high-end places
that were nice and this is kind of this
is kind of what i learned now a year
later from that kind of process the
first one is that i i think the idea
that i had of wanting to have an
unlimited credit card and just consume
my lifestyle at least the lifestyle and
then walk away from wherever i was and
just leave it behind the cool part about
it was like we could go we're like where
do we want to go next but i think that
after having done it i really did miss
the elements of familiarity of having
people who knew you all around having
social circles you know like you can't
stay somewhere for a month and then and
really get to know people or build any
kind of meaningful relationships so that
was kind of not as expected i just
didn't think through it the other one
that was kind of interesting for me was
was i didn't have all my stuff around me
like i have gone very accustomed to
having like my little spot where i have
all the stuff that i like and you're
like well alex you're in a closet right
now and that's because i'm in a tiny
condo and i actually don't like windows
where i work because for me i get super
easily distracted and i'll just start
out the window and like 30 minutes will
go by it i wouldn't even realize it um
and so that is why i'm in a closet for
those who are like why do you have so
much money and why do you have such a
shitty office that's why
beyond that you can't really make
changes to
long-term rentals the way you can a
house you will probably like things a
certain way and i think the more the
more money you have and the more you
learn about yourself the more particular
you sometimes become because you've just
realized that these are things that add
attention back in your life so you get
more bandwidth and so i have a lot of
particulars you know i mean in terms of
like how i like i like having a
recording studio i don't have one right
now that's why we're here but i like
having a recording studio i like having
a gym that's like in my house that's
commercial level or within walking
distance from me because i just like
being able to work out when i want to
work out and not have it be like a thing
i like i like the mess the you know the
sweet views but it's also like i like
all my stuff in the kitchen you know
what i mean like i like my sauces and my
my my supplements and just the stuff
that i there's just my stuff you know
what i mean and in the least your
lifestyle thing like i think there's
there's i over corrected for like i
don't like having stuff to going all the
way the other way where i had nothing
and i think that it's probably more in
the middle and so i'll tell you what we
ended up settling on i think that as you
as you become more you know
ultra wealthy whatever you want to call
it like as you as you level up and the
reason i'm making this is because like i
didn't know this as i was going into it
so hopefully i can just help someone
avoid the over-correction that i made is
that i think the ideal setup is having
two to three maybe four primary homes
that you actually stock with all your
stuff in the meantime so you can just
basically pick up and leave so you have
the flexibility of moving but you have
the familiarity of like your things and
then in the meantime you can still go
travel but you still have like a home
base not having a home base uh was not
advisable i felt kind of like i felt
like a nomad but like free-floating in a
way that i didn't like um and i realized
that over time as we were kind of going
through this process one of the other
realizations that i had was around
hedonic adaptation which is basically
like as you get exposed to uh new cool
stuff eventually you get used to it and
it no longer confers any value and so
like people get this you know can this
can this can be real for you in terms of
like if you've ever bought a new car um
it's really cool for the first however
long and then within like a month or two
it's just like that's the car i have
right and some people are like car super
enthusiasts but even then they buy
another car and buy other cars because
they kind of get used to hedonic
adaptation the things that you had and
so
um leila and i did this like uh pooled
leasing thing where we like can swap out
our car whenever we want so it's like
you pay a fixed price i think it's like
a thousand bucks a month and then you
can like swap your car whenever you want
uh but you pay for like you but you
commit to like a year so anyways kind of
interesting you think that you're gonna
switch cards out but then you never want
to do the pain in the ass and so i've
actually had the exact same car since
day one um so it's like some of these
things you think you're going to do and
then you don't actually end up doing it
which for me was like a fun uh
interesting thing and my uh my
videographer was like hey man you should
answer this question so he sent me these
questions for this video which was like
how do you how do you see materialism
and so i having you know having had the
ability to buy pretty much whatever i
want you know including private jets and
things like that i
know that for me
not only do most of those things not
bring me joy but i actually feel a
certain amount of like wastefulness and
maybe that's just something that's
internalized to me uh but like i just i
don't like waste in general and so to me
it just it actually it's almost net
negative and buying things for the sake
of status i've gotten over that a long
long time ago i don't really the only
thing i ever bought that would i think i
would consider like a status symbol was
i got a bentley which is one of the cars
i sold last year it was a flying spur
was brand new it was like 300 and
something thousand and i got it because
a lot of people like dude you never
spend money like you should live a
little bit and so i was like okay i'll
try it and i i used it and i'll say the
benefits of having the exotic car this
is the only benefit that i think
functionally helped is that when you
pull up to places people do treat you
better and so
i enjoyed the higher level of service
but i think there was kind of a taint to
it because i knew that i didn't get that
treatment when i would have just a
normal car and then it made me like see
people in a worse way which is which is
crappy i probably shouldn't have made
that conclusion but i like flying under
the radar and just doing my own thing um
and that definitely attracted attention
so there's there's elements that were
good there was elements that were bad uh
was it worth the money absolutely not i
don't really care about cars at all um
and i did it
definitely for the wrong reason but in
some ways i'm glad i did so that i can
just say like i now know that for me
it's useless so maybe that'll save you
three hundred thousand dollars in a
waste of a car and then you know what do
i think about jets uh private jet wise i
think it's really nice for travel to be
honest with you like it's one of the few
things that i still spend money on uh
because there's a there's a lot of
function for it right like and people
are like how can you not like waste and
then do that well the jet is already
there and it's either sitting there or
it's being used so in some ways i'm
actually less wasteful as i'm using it
but
the relative cost and people really have
to understand this is like i've taken
home more than a million dollars a month
for the last half decade so like just
imagine like a million dollars hits your
bank account and then a month goes by
and another million dollars hits your
bank account and then another month goes
by and then another million dollars and
then you do that for years and then all
of a sudden like the cost of things
relative to your income becomes very
very low i'll give you a math example to
explain this but like let's say you just
did 10 million which is less than a
million dollars a month fyi if you took
on 10 million dollars a year and the
average american family takes home 50
000 a year then
everything so it's 200 times more money
than the average american family and so
if something costs let's say 10 000
right divide that by 200 and you've got
50
and so it cost 50 bucks
for me relatively to take a private
flight if you if you're not at that
income level yet i'm trying to make it
relative so it makes sense but like if
you had the option of immediately
pulling your car up getting on the plane
having no one else on the plane getting
to your destination having a car there
already packed with your stuff you get
out of the plane into the car on the
runway so it's literally like you drive
two hours and then you drive again and
so it's like literally just the transit
time is the transit time which makes all
of the us way more accessible to you and
for me i don't waste days i'm not
exhausted i don't have like a recovery
period and i'm more likely to travel
because the hassle is low and what it
does do and this is the biggest thing
that i can communicate of flying private
is that it it
it shifts it transforms
transport from a negative experience to
a positive experience it's not even like
i would say like traveling first class
still overall a negative experience just
less negative but uh but flying private
is almost i would say a positive
experience and so that is really the
biggest transformation that happens when
you fly private which is why i still do
it but i just wanted to give you guys an
example but like if that if you were
able to transform the experience from
negative to positive not have the the
the drain the men the mental and
emotional drain the energy drain the the
recovery time that would have to occur
the prep time the getting your documents
the defining the flights and all that
kind of stuff if you got if you got to
skip all that um would you pay 50 for
that rather than paying a dollar right
most people would make that difference
right it's like it's a buck for normal
normal flight and 50 for the for the
private one like a lot of people i think
would make that trade and so that's the
reason that people you know why people
who have more do make that trade is
because like relative to income it makes
more sense okay so the the last piece
i'm gonna hit on is kind of like my
unifying theory in terms of how i make
decisions around material goods because
it's like okay i have i had a lot of
stuff a lot a decent amount of stuff
sold it all lived almost a year on the
road uh with just a bag and now uh layla
and i just bought a home a very nice
home it's an eight-figure house so i'll
just believe that's really nice house
and it's on a mountaintop and it's
really cool but i like it a lot why why
would i do that after this whole period
so number one is i do think it's
necessary or at least for me i don't
want to speak that over you but like for
me
i prefer
having
a home base a headquarters where all my
stuff is and so i think that from there
we can do the travels we can do the
consumption but then we have some place
to come back to
and so that's number one number two is
that from a work season which is what
i'm entering again now because i'm we're
building up acquisition.com company so
we're taking all the portfolio companies
actively as we speak right now that are
in that you know e-learning and service
space business service consumer services
and growing those companies actively
right now and it's a ton of fun and
there's nothing that's more interesting
to me and so for me like i don't need
any stimulation from my exterior
surroundings because i get so much
stimulation from the work that i do and
so that is that is paramount that is the
the biggest priority and so that's where
the home base becomes really helpful
because i'm just more efficient and more
productive when i have all the things
that i already know that work well for
me around me and so from a unifying
theory standpoint it comes down to form
over function and so
i will spend money on things that are
expensive i'll use quotes here if they
have improved function and so i don't
have one of my flannels with me but like
the flannels that i wear are actually
really expensive and it's just because
they like fit me really well and i like
them and so i buy them this on the other
hand i get five packs from amazon for
like 10 bucks and so like because i've
had the really expensive like lululemon
tank tops and stuff and like i like
these
cheap cotton ones better they breathe
better and they don't they don't bother
me and i they're interchangeable and
they can get dirty when i go to the gym
and if something tears i don't care
right um and so that's
that's why i wear these things right and
so from from a form perspective or so
from a function perspective that is what
i make all my decisions based on and so
i think that for uh having kind of lived
the entire spectrum if you can have a
unifying theory around how you buy
things i think it would be incredibly
helpful and from a clothing perspective
this is a nice one that i that i picked
up is i've realized that lots of
clothing actually decreases my quality
of life and so when i walk into a closet
and i see lots of clothes or lots of
t-shirts i feel guilty um and maybe i
could fix that about myself but for me
it's much less effort to just fix the
surrounding and so i realized when i
gave away 90 of my clothing and just
kept 10 for the bag that i actually felt
better and i was like huh okay so this
is something that i'm keeping with me
even though i'm going to a headquarters
that has all my stuff clothing is not
among them that are meaningful to me and
so if i'm going to buy something i have
to in my mind i'll throw something else
out so that way my my actual closet
stays around stays the same size but the
quality always increases in terms of
like it's net utility to me and so i
have to take out something that's the
lowest utility shirt or shorts and then
replace it with something that has
higher utility overall and as a fun side
note i have found that for me if i find
a shirt that i like i will buy six
colors that i like in that shirt and i
will usually replace in bulk the other
t-shirts that i had prior to that that
didn't fit me necessarily as well as
these ones did um and so you're like are
you really talking to me about these
things well these are the things that
you that you think through as you're
trying to optimize different aspects of
your life so that you can make better
decisions and have more headspace
throughout the day so you can ultimately
make more money or at least that's how i
function that is the that is kind of
where we landed was uh the one really
really really nice home and we will
probably buy another place that will be
in the summer and winter and so weather
which i should have mentioned earlier
was a primary driving factor and so i
figure that between two and three
climates i can have the weather that i
want year round with the novelty of
change of environment without having the
nomad feeling of not having any of my
stuff and so that is kind of the plan
that we are moving through right now is
having two to three homes in different
areas with different vibes so probably
beach mountain and then probably lake uh
would be like the baby desert just have
different vibes and then like in the
summers when it's really hot in you know
like vegas then i'll go somewhere that's
really cool and so that way i can kind
of get the best of everything and not
also have to be like on the track you
know on the road all the time because to
me that is also somewhat stressful now
having done it for a year i made this
video because i did not know this as i
was coming up and i thought first i
should have lots of stuff and i did that
and that weighed me down and then i
transitioned to selling everything and
just leasing my lifestyle and when i did
that i realized that i did like having
some stuff maybe not all of it and so i
think that like buddha the middle path
is the way and so you can have the
nothing and you can have everything and
i think that everyone just has to figure
out what the just right is for you but
for me my unifying theory around it is
form over function sorry function over
form so what it does for me and the net
utility it provides me in my life is the
primary driving factor and then that
gives me a decision-making process that
makes my life easier because like we
make thousands of decisions every day as
an entrepreneur and if you can have a
unifying theory it's kind of a decision
algorithm like if this than that then
you can pre-make decisions and then you
can always just run them through the
algorithm without having to like use
mental bandwidth and so in another video
i'll walk you through like i've tons and
tons of decision algorithms that i've
already made to just make my life easier
um so that i can only so that i can
allocate all of my time to making new
decisions rather than remaking old ones
um and so if you like this my name is
alex mosey again welcome to mozy nation
i hope you enjoyed the video and i'll
see you in the next one bye